north of scotland later the far north
will be cloudier and breezier with rain
at times on saturday but elsewhere will
be dry with plenty of sunny spells and
temperatures peaking around 26 to 29
celsius in the south
the rain in northern scotland will sink
a little further south across scotland
during the afternoon and spells of rain
are possible in northern ireland
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
this is sky news tonight coming up our
panel of experts will answer your
questions about the extreme heat coming
our way and what we can do about it
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back well let's get more now on
that red weather warning from the met
office and the declaration of a national
emergency as the uk faces record
temperatures next week we've been asking
you for your questions throughout the
day and let's get some answers for you
now i'm joined by alex deakin a
meteorologist at the met office
alongside rose gallagher a practicing
nurse who is professional lead for
infection prevention and control at the
royal college of nursing and susan
schofield a former director of the
cabinet offices civil contingencies
secretariat
good evening to you all thanks very much
indeed for being with us tonight for
what is uh for all of us an
unprecedented time isn't it um we've got
a range of questions from right around
the country so what i'll do is i'll put
i'll put the relevant question to the
relevant expert sometimes maybe two of
you can answer the same question too for
us so i'll let you know who it's
addressed to as well so let's start with
a question from george then um
he's asking um why are we declaring a
national emergency when other countries
in warmer climates that we visit for
holiday seem to cope okay susan
schofield i'll put that to you
okay well i think it's because we need
to think through early the consequences
and declaring that national emergency
make us do that thing so we're prepared
for the worst but we really hope it
won't happen
we've got rather a lot going on at the
moment and the knock-on effects from one
department to another are not always
obvious and you need to think them
through
um i'll i'll put that to you as well
rose uh do you think um we're just kind
of built differently in the uk and and
that's why we're not able to cope as
well
well the temperatures that we're
expecting to see are extreme for the
united kingdom
so we don't live
our lives such as those in the
mediterranean countries for example
who know and adapt to life with you know
high temperatures throughout the summer
so this is a really clear warning to us
to be careful with our behavior and
respect nature for the few days where
the temperatures are going to be really
high
okay a question from rob how likely are
we to get power cuts and travel be
impacted susan schofield another one for
you really
yes well i suppose that's what i was
trying to say earlier it's precisely
planning to avoid the need to do it
now some of the impacts may not be
immediately obvious transport for
example
road rails will be familiar don't like
these sorts of high temperatures so how
we adapt to travel safely in those types
of this is exactly the reasoning forward
plan
so what is it that we need to do then
what is the adaptation that needs to
take place
well it's in in that case i think i've
heard uh uh the trains will be driving
more slowly for example but in each case
it needs to be thought through
ideally so there isn't then something
that does cause park uh cuts and
stoppages and those kind of things
okay are we safe to work in these
temperatures steve l is asking that i'm
going to bring in alex deakin
meteorologist at the met office good to
have you with us uh tonight i'll ask you
that first before we go to rose for it
as well how safe are we
well i actually quite like to answer
that first question about infrastructure
and how people cope with these kind of
temperatures in other countries you're
not comparing like with like the
infrastructure in this country is not
ready to cope with the kind of
temperatures that we're talking about
unprecedented values when you go on
holiday you're kind of preparing for
your body's preparing for it and the
infrastructure in those countries is set
up
you have air conditioning and it's
really those night time temperatures as
well as the daytime temperatures that
are going to cause the problems because
people won't be able to sleep as well
and if your body doesn't get that rest
then it really struggles to cope in the
high temperatures in terms of how hot is
it to be to be able to work well that
that is a question for each employer to
look at these are unprecedented
temperatures every workplace is
different so it's up to the employer to
make sure that
people are safe in their work
environment but these are unprecedented
temperatures and we're going to see
extremes and they are going to cause
serious issues yeah i'm going to put
that back to you so susan schofield
because i was kind of expecting that
kind of answer from you as well i mean
if you think about it when we do go
abroad we do see you know higher
ceilings and different shaped buildings
that they have adapted
presumably we haven't adapted fast
enough to the fact that we kind of
haven't needed to
but i very much agree with rose's point
there are things we can do to adapt our
behavior um immediately
things like you know close your curtains
during the day arguably in some cases
your windows but open them up at night
and that's where you get a better
night's sleep i mean we are where we are
at the moment with our infrastructure
but that's precisely why we need to be
thinking through this is going to be
more typical for the future are there
changes we we need to make and similarly
we've been talking about this in making
our homes more fuel efficient for
example
so adding to that work that's always
underway
but these are further dimensions that
maybe we have factored into our planning
um rose gallagher um as a nurse you know
how are are we safe to work in these
temperatures and it's not just all of us
out here it's also members of the nhs
who are going to be under extreme
pressure too aren't they
they they are indeed i think i'd like to
start by saying that employers know have
known and know now that these high
temperatures are coming so they should
be putting in place plans now to support
their workers and keep them safe
you know heat is really dangerous we
should be really really clear about
how heat can affect
individuals and how we need to adapt our
work if we can
to keep ourselves safe and cool so for
the nhs
there will be healthcare professionals
including nurses the midwives that will
be working in hospitals but also
traveling in their cars out in community
settings caring for patients in their
homes
so they they are going to need to stay
well hydrated they're going to need that
need their employers to put in place um
actions to ensure they have adequate
breaks but that's very hard when the
hospitals are full um and demand is so
high for other employers of course they
may be able to adapt when people go to
work you may be able to start earlier
you may potentially be able to work at
home and avoid travel if your job can do
that and it's maybe cooler
at home for other people it will be
cooler in the office so they may decide
to go into work um because it's cooler
but all of us need to wear light
clothing we need to drink adequately and
we need to take it easy
yeah absolutely some good advice there
i'm sure everyone here in the studio is
definitely grateful for the aircon when
we come into work we're unusually
happier to be at work these days
than to be at home okay alex i'm gonna
bring you back in um because we've got a
question from bethany who's asking will
this weather get worse in the years to
come
heat waves are getting more severe
getting more ferocious they're lasting
longer and temperatures are rising and
that's all part of climate change we are
going to see these temperatures more
frequently and we are going to see uh
heat waves as i say becoming more fresh
so what we're talking about next week is
an absolute extreme but heat waves are
as i say becoming longer live there's
lots and lots of evidence around that
and temperatures are getting higher so
it is something we're going to need to
to be prepared for and park the met
office is to look at the science and
feed that into government and to help
with the infrastructure around that so i
think it is something we need to be
aware of and yeah we do need to prepare
for it
this this is an interesting one um uh
how do pregnant women
work during the extreme heat gosh i know
so i i have a number of friends who are
pregnant at the moment they tell me they
feel like incubators so rose gallagher
how do they cope in the heat
well first of all um pregnant women
whether you're in the early or the late
stages need to adapt
over the next few days so pregnant women
are at greater risk of becoming
dehydrated their bodies are working
harder because
they are pregnant so they need to make
sure that they drink plenty they should
be aware that they are more susceptible
to heat and the risks of dehydration so
stay in the shade if you can talk to
your employer make adjustments if you
can if you can work from home or if
you're not working then see if you can
take a nap and if you're concerned talk
to your midwife
um that's that's the advice that we
would give
can i ask i i know that a lot of people
have recommended to me and i've done it
when i've worked in hot countries you
run cold water on your wrist
um because that's where your pulse is
does that work is that an old wives tale
i mean it works for me maybe it's in my
head
i'm not sure i'm not sure about that i
mean i carried a pregnancy in a hot
country as well it was 28 degrees at
night when i was heavily pregnant
and it really was about having very
loose clothing keeping the bedroom
curtains closed as you said spraying
water on your face actually can make you
feel
more comfortable it's important though
that people around you if you have
partners living with you or relatives
that they keep an eye out for you we all
need to keep an eye out for each other
during this hot spot whether it's
elderly relatives or vulnerable people
such as pregnant women or those with
long-term conditions so be be prepared
okay um uh we've got so many more
questions from right around the country
to get through um we'll carry on after
the break but first before we go to a
break we've got one last one from hayden
who hasn't disclosed his age but he's
asking will people still have to go to
school
susan i'm going to ask you that um i
know that a number of schools are on a
very serious note have actually
um uh uh said they're going to close or
tel telling kids to stay at home next
week
how do you think the government should
handle this
well i think again
in principle put in place measures that
make that not unnecessary would be ideal
but in individual cases the building
might be of such a nature and actually
we've had quite a lot of experience with
covered in this sort of way that means
actually they can't make the changes
that others can that's why it's
important not only to have this on the
national approach but also the the local
um is very important and individual
businesses individual schools may not
all come up with the same answer
okay um stay with us we're going to get
through a lot more questions but you are
watching sky news coming up more of your
questions and answers from the panel
about the warning and a reminder it is
going to be extremely hot weather we
have a national emergency declared
[Music]
beautiful hysteria here
in the final hours of boys johnson
premiership he just let himself rip from
the great british public and this is a
result
i want you to know how sad i am to be
giving up the best job in the world he
wants to tell people stories and he is
utterly cavalier with the fans thank you
you never apologize you never admit
mistakes ultimately you know you get
caught
i'm mark stone and i'm
respondent based here in washington d.c
well the plan seems to be to head to the
police station where the policeman who
fired the shots was based
[Music]
and everything you know his memories is
all gone
[Music]
in almost every corner this town has
been completely destroyed by the fire
i've witnessed the remarkable passion
for politics here but the anger too
trump out of the white house is this the
moment to reform gun laws
you know it's it's easy to go to
politics but it's important it's at the
heart of the issue i i get that that's
where the media likes to go it's not
it's where many of the people we've
talked to here like to go i report on
the biggest stories from around the
world
this is a town that is effectively
encircled
by the russians
you say it's all fabrication what's
happening in butcher
destroyed my nation
we take you to the heart of stories that
shape our planet
i can hear now quite a few explosions uh
in the distance here in jerusalem a very
violent series of confrontations here
what do you think of isis everybody here
know the truth of isis
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm dan whitehead and i'm sky news's
west of england correspondent
from fishing communities to bustling
cities we spend every day reporting from
across the region
welcome back we're answering your
questions about the extreme weather
heading to the uk while we're already in
the midst of it aren't we which has
triggered a red warning from the met
office for next week let's talk to our
panel of experts alex deacon
meteorologist susan schofield former
director of the uh
cabinet office's civil contingency
secretariat and rose gallagher who's a
nurse and public health expert from the
royal college of nursing
alex deakin i i want to come to you now
because of course whatever we have
extreme weather whether that's snow and
blizzards and storms and hurricanes or
like we're experiencing the uk's first
ever red alert and national emergency
we talk about climate change is this
an example of climate change is this
what is happening right now
a natural climate always has
variabilities we've had hot spells in
the past but what is absolutely clear is
that these hot spells these heat waves
are becoming more intense and more
frequent the science is absolutely clear
that um climate change is its
fingerprints all over this current hot
spell when it's over we'll do what's
called an attribution study and we're
about to put a number to it how much
more likely it was because of human
human induced climate change than if we
hadn't had it what we know at this stage
is that 40 degrees celsius is now 10
times more likely in the uk than it
would be under a a naturally bearing um
climate so one that humans haven't
influenced so yes we are going to
experience these kind of heat waves more
and more frequently
and there will be as i say a study done
straight afterwards i'm pretty confident
we'll say there's there's a high
likelihood that this is down to human
induced climate change we will have had
a hot spell we're always going to see
hot spells but but this is that extra
that extra layer we all talk about one
degree of warming and people don't quite
understand why we then talk about these
extremes of temperatures but that one to
one degree is a global average
and you get local variations and you're
just pushing the boundaries you're
pushing the extremes so we're at that
extreme end with the temperatures we're
looking at and because of climate change
we've just taken it on that extra notch
and that's why we're talking about
record-breaking temperatures that's
really interesting i didn't realize you
had to study afterwards to work out
whether this was impacted by
the introduction of what humans are
doing
there for global warming
well that's just to get the numbers
right so to get the exact numbers so we
we know exactly how hot it's it's got uh
you know it could be 37 it could be 39
or how long the heat wave is going to
last so we need the stats in so that you
can then run the computer models to to
compare and contrast that's that's why
you kind of wait for the numbers but but
the science is clear heat waves are
becoming more and more frequent they're
becoming more intense and they're
lasting longer so you know every
heatwave has some kind of element of
human induced climate change it'll just
be a question of putting the numbers on
once we've got the final temperatures
but again i just want to stress whether
we get to 41 or 39
you know people get hung up on the
numbers me as a meteorologist i do as
well and certainly in the media we get
kind of fascinated by the numbers but
it's kind of irrelevant what we're
talking about here a lot you know health
impacts will be severe whether it's 37
or 41 it's that longevity of those top
temperatures and the nighttime
temperatures as well because we could
break records in terms of uh highest
ever minimum so it's that longevity and
it's the intensity of the heat whether
we get as i say to 41 or 37. right okay
well on that uh um we've had a question
rose gallagher from a viewer saying i
have a toddler who is unwell with a
temperature how can i best keep her cool
in this hot weather
well it's really hard because children
don't understand um when we ask them to
sit still always because it's hot so but
there are some basic things that we can
all do to keep toddlers tall so cool so
first of all dress them in cool clothing
and offer them perhaps cool baths or
showers if you don't have a bath
throughout the day really important that
they stay
well hydrated so so keep an eye on their
nappies if they're in nappies or make
sure that they're going to the toilet
and if they're old enough then perhaps a
fan that might be comforting
for them i think it's really important
to be flexible in terms of what you do
throughout the day and obviously if you
have to go out make sure they wear a hat
and try and avoid hot cars but one of
the most important things is to actually
be aware of the signs of heat exhaustion
in people and that includes children
children can become floppy
they can become quite sleepy and hard to
rouse if that happens you should seek
urgent medical advice
thank you for that um it's really
worrying isn't it um
uh susan scoldfield we've had a question
asking would the government in a red
warning ever consider shutting the
country down to prevent any incidents
from people requiring medical aid or
hospitalization
well in a sense never say never but
that's precisely why you do your
planning
to make sure that you don't get and
fundamentally as close you can get to
business as normal continues that's the
whole reason for doing emergency
planning and being prepared for the
extreme that's precisely what one
doesn't want to have to do
now the other thing and i very much echo
what colleagues are saying
is therefore what government also needs
to do in which the national red crisis
triggers is give people good ideas of
what they might do
and encourage every
family every business you know there's
also the national business to have its
thinking done and its plans and its well
its hats in place or you know whatever
have those options ready and available
so so what are the top three or four
bullet points you would give that people
should do i mean
we're saying there's a national
emergency we're saying there's a heat
wave we're saying it's dangerous to
vulnerable and people who aren't
vulnerable what should they be thinking
of doing
well i think stay inside if you possibly
can
work from home as we've heard if you
possibly can if you do need to go out
make sure you
you know you're properly dressed and the
point about staying hydrated um i think
is a really really central one so these
are all quite simple things that we can
all do it's interesting rose um there's
also the flip side to staying hydrated
isn't there where you can drink too much
water and and remove the salts in your
body and stuff so what's the right
amount of water
well heat exhaustion occurs when your
body's not able to cool down so you've
basically become dehydrated very simply
put so you should be drinking at least a
glass of water an hour possibly more
depending on what you're doing and the
environment that you're in
so um as nurses we we encourage people
when they go to the toilet if they've
got dark urine it means you're probably
not drinking enough but you're right we
don't want people drinking liters and
liters of water and washing out the
salts
in their body okay
very quickly we've got one minute left
we've got one last question from rich
who's saying how best can you prevent
sunburn if you get burnt what's the best
way to relieve the effects
i would say loose
loose clothing obviously cut make sure
your skin is covered and use a high
factor sun cream okay that's brilliant
thanks very much indeed we've
got all the way through that um alex i'm
sorry did you have something to say
there my producer's saying that alex you
might have something to say yeah just
the best way to avoid somebody is to
avoid the sun at those big times uv
levels are going to be uh very high in
places this weekend so avoid those times
elevenths or three and if you do have to
go outside during those peak times uh
you know walk in the shade where a wide
brimmed hat the best way is
is to avoid you know getting exposing
your your skin to the sun at all
absolutely
sorry susan
dogs can get sunburned i understand also
yeah protect your pets too exactly
absolutely so susan schofield alex
deakin rose gallagher thanks very much
indeed for answering uh questions from
our viewers tonight good to have you
with us stay safe
okay let's take a look at the weather in
detail for you now
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
well the heat's building over the uk and
ireland this weekend with a risk of
dangerous and record-breaking
temperatures early next week as we've
been discussing many places will have a
fine end to friday with any showers
becoming confined to the northeast of
england and